♪ Je parle pas chiac,
je parle crétaque ♪
♪ Je parle pas micmac,
Je parle whisky Jack ♪
- je suis vraiment content
de vous rencontrer parce que
vous incarnez, pour moi,
l'artiste libre. Vous avez...
vous avez travaillé u u u u u ue
"Maudit silence", et j'ai un pet
l'oeuvre de votre vie.
CHLOÉ SAINTE-MARIE,
- Vous avez raison, en ce sens
que c'est laèse de toute
ma vie, de tout ce que j'ai
fait, de tout ce que j'ai dit,
ça. Je voulais voulais faire
une sorte de parcours, résumé,
synthèse. Puis, c'est vrai
ce que vous dites.
♪ (MaLaLaLaLaLaLaLaLaLaLaLaLaLa,
c'est que c'est
qui nous fait voyager.
Vous chantez en innu,
en créole haïtien, en portugais,
et vous mcococococococococococo.
- Beaucoup, beaucoup. Mais,
j'ai voyagé beaucoup. Puis ça,
c'est toutes des langues,
au fond, latines, titititititit.
Alors oui. Puis mes voyages,
j'ai... j'ai d'abord été à Haïti
en 201dadadadadadadadadadadadad,
mais j'ai fait un voyage a
Jean Moricet. On est parti
en Patagonie. Quand j'entends
Lola Kiepja qui chante et qui
dit ces poèmes sur l'Album,
on l'entend, eh bien, é é é é é,
les Patagons. C'vrvrvraiment
puissant comme...
ce qu'on ressent.
- Sur "Maudit silence", vous000,
vous aviez aussi réalisé
un album complètement en innu
avec Joséphine Bacon, et c'est
elle qui vous a appris q q q q .
(en innu)
- Tu ne connais pas
mon histoire.
Bacon. Au fond, je l'ai connue
en 1982, au m m m moment que
j'ai connu Gilles Carle et
Gaston Miron. Alors,
à trois branches ça.
(rire)
Puis Joséphine, elle m'a...
une sorte de d'amitié.
Comme deux soeurs qui...
qu'elle m'a do p p p p p p p p .
Wyoming, Nebraska ♪
de descendance métis. D'où
vous est venue cette passion
pour la culture autochtone?
- Mon ancêtre, il est arrivé
- Oui, mais c'est pas lui qui
vous donner la pononon là.
- Mais je l'ai dans le sang!
(rires)
- C'est un truchement. Il a
isisis les langues autochtones.
Il est allé, comme on disait
à l'époque, évangélisera a a a ,
avec le Père Lemoine, puis
j'ai... c'est... j'ai ça
dans le sang. Je veux dire...st.
Je veux dire, c'est la même
lignée... du côté de ma mère,
au Wisconsin, c'est dans
ma lignée aussi. Don
les courailleurs des bois,
j'en fais partie.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un retour en arrière,
le premier livre que vous avez
vous venez d'une famille assezc.
Ça, c'est dans le coin
- Ouais, dans les terres plates.
C'est plat... le plat pays.
- Donc, à quel é é é é é é é é e
d'artiste?
- Bien, pour moi, c'est la même
chose. T'sais, la... il y a
je pense que c'est Jean
Beaunoyer : "Les artistes,
c'est les derniers croyants"
et je peux vous t t t t t t t te
artiste, il faut y croire.
Tu vis... t'sais, Regardez...
les poètes aussi, qui viventnsnu
d'argent, faut enseigner
comme poète.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Vous ouvrez latetete, là,
justement parce que pour
votre disque d'avant,
semble-t-il que vous vous êtes
ené é é de plus de 100000$?
J'ai comme l'impression que
vous êtes allergique à l'arg
(rires)
- Je suis allergique à l'argent
parce que j'ai accepté de mourir
pauvre. C'est unutututututututue
une boutade, mais c'est pas
une boutade. C'est quand
on prend la décision eptptptptp:
"j'accepte de mourir pauvre",
des choses. Tout, tout, tout,to.
Puis, on prend des décisions
dans une liberté totale.
♪ Robert, Robert,
où est ton arbre? ♪
- Vous êtes lamémémémémémémémém,
Gilles Carle, qui nous a quitté
il y a près de 13 ans.
Comment vous habite-t-il
- Il m'habite tous les jours.
Je l'engueule tous les jou
(rires)
Je l
Je pleure avec lui. Je lui dis :
"Aide-moi, dans quoi je me suis
embarquée encore?" Je vous jureé
la communication avec Gilles
Carle. Je lui parle et
je vais toujours lui parler.
- Chloé Sainte-Marie, Merci
beaucoup pour cet entretien et
j'ai bien icicicicicicicicicicir
votre rentrée montréalaise.
Merci.
- Merci, merci beaucoup.